لم تعاقب إدارة بايدن
بشكل مباشر
ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان
بعد
مقتل الصحفي جمال خاشقجي على الرغم من وجود
تقرير استخباراتي
يقول إنه مسؤول بشكل مباشر
عن الموافقة
على مقتله وأن الرئيس بايدن لم
يتردد في وصف فلاديمير بوتين بالقاتل
هل تعتبر  محمد بن سلمان
قاتل
دونا إليكم ما فعلناه ومن
المهم أه التقرير الذي
أشرت إليه
وضعناه في ضوء النهار إنه
ليس تقريرًا كتب
قبل أسبوعين إنه كان
جالسًا.  لفترة وجيزة
وضعناها وهذا في حد ذاته
مهم
لأنه ليس هناك أي شيء جديد
في التقرير
من حيث ما تم
الإبلاغ عنه سابقًا ولكن حقيقة أن
حكومة الولايات المتحدة
وضعت تصريحها على  هذا التقرير وعلى
تلك المعلومة
أه بما أه مسئولية
مقتل السيد خاشقجي
أعتقد أنها بحد ذاتها مهمة
ثانية أه نحن
عاقب عددًا من
المشاركين المباشرين في
أه في مقتل السيد خاشقجي
وربما المضي قدمًا بشكل كبير
للتأكد من أن أفضل ما لدينا من
قدرات لن يحدث مرة أخرى
أه وضعنا مكانًا أه نسميه
حظر خاشقجي
الذي يتأكد  أن كل
من يقوم نيابة عن حكومة أه يحاول
تخويف
أه إسكات أه أو يسيء
إلى شخص أه يتحدث ضد
أه ضد تلك الحكومة سواء كانت
معارضة أو معارضة سياسية أو
صحفية
حسناً سنحرص على ذلك
الشخص  لا تطأ قدمها في الولايات
المتحدة وهذا لا ينطبق فقط على المملكة
العربية السعودية بل ينطبق
أه أه حول العالم أه وهكذا أه أعتقد
أه وأنا أفهم كل ذلك كل
هذا الاتجاه
في نفس
الوقت الشفافية هي أفهم الجميع  من
تلك الشفافية ولكن حقيقة أن
هذه الشفافية التي
قلتها آسف لأن التأخير قليل جدًا ،
دعني أدخل وأقول فقط
إنك كنت شفافًا ولديك
لقد كان
واضحًا جدًا بشأن دوره
دور ولي العهد السعودي ،
فهل هو قاتل
، ها هي الحقيقة الأخرى التي هي
مهمة جدًا بالنسبة
لنا علينا أن نفعلها عندما نتعامل يوميًا في
جميع أنحاء العالم
أه مع قادة الدول أه من يفعل
الأشياء التي نجدها إما أه
من مرفوض إلى بغيض أه لكن
من حيث النهوض الفعلي
بمصالحنا والنهوض بقيمنا
أه المهم أه التعامل معها
أه
يرجح أن يكون ولي العهد أه
قائد المملكة العربية السعودية
بعيدًا في المستقبل نحن  لديك اهتمام قوي
على سبيل المثال
في أه العمل لإنهاء الحرب في اليمن أه
ربما أسوأ أزمة إنسانية
في العالم ستأخذ
مشاركة هادفة من قبل أه السعوديين ونفعل
ذلك وقد أحرزنا بالفعل تقدمًا حقيقيًا
في هذا الاتجاه في  آخر
أه في الشهرين الأخيرين
أه القيام بذلك سيرفع القيم
التي نعتز بها
في حماية أرواح
المدنيين الأبرياء
أه هناك أه من ناحية التقدم أه
حقوق الإنسان والتقدم في المملكة العربية السعودية نفسها ،
هل من الأفضل لنا
أم إعادة ضبط العلاقة كما فعلنا
أو تمزقها أه وأعتقد أنه
من حيث إحداث فرق فعلي
في الأشياء التي نهتم بإعادة
المعايرة كان ضروريًا للغاية
وكان الرئيس كذلك  واضح بشأن
ذلك ولكن تمزيق العلاقة في
الواقع لن يساعدنا في تعزيز
مصالحنا أو قيمنا